following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fold to you that's why we and Baltic
have prepared these educational
materials for you to better understand
the seven defining attributes that make
you special now let's discuss the uses
of agility a nuclear blast and the
subsequent fallout will have many
adverse effects on life as we know it
intensive prolonged radiation exposure
may transform those above ground into
decrepit rotting beings that have lost
their ability to reason they will likely
be without common manners and quick to
anger you must learn to make the most of
available firearms enthusiasm will only
take you so far now let's try that again
and remember that with your impressive
agility you can act more decisively in
vance see it's a snap agility can also
help you out in difficult moments
but why place yourself under undue
stress instead try a simpler route
taking the quieter approach is always
worth consideration your agility can
turn a sneak attack into a complete
tactical move keep in mind others may
have the same bright idea your agility
will help you move through the wasteland
with ease and yield other benefits like
assaulting an unsuspecting dreamer for
the Kenan hastily reloading your
firearms by piling on damage to
additional targets when the firm
regularly study your vault-tec provided
materials to prepare for survival and to
answer the question do you know what
makes you special
you